qu'est ce que t'as foutu
j'ai pas si mal et je lui dis que
j'étais galop 2 alors elle elle m'a
demandé de le remplacer pour une
promenade en forêt à poney bon c'était
bien parti mais il a rien un moment là
le poney peut-être qui s'est emballé tu
as clair de lune et abricots qui suivent
moi je passe par dessus la tête de pont
rouge
au final il a fallu deux heures pour les
rattraper dans la forêt est la même à
qu'on a retrouvé sur le parking de
vélizy 2 générations à cheval christ
était de raconter ça mais c'est pas mon
vieux bas vous plaît ce sont des quads
accroche en photo mais je suis bloqué
devant elle
ça se confirme c'est bien bloqué of tu
vois c'est con parce que vraiment mal
commencé à me parler
bon c'était pas des tirades évidemment
m'enfin on était bien mais là c'est moi
qu'elle attend ses morts ses morts c'est
peut-être pas mort ce formidable confié
doit percevoir chaque fois c'est des
analyses d'une finesse on a des
nouvelles de christine coûte apparemment
et aux seychelles est bizarre en ce
moment m tu vas pas t'inquiéter comme ça
parce que moi qui vous voient leur
quotidien
je peux dire que vraiment tué une femme
qui tu aimes tu as beaucoup de chance de
l'avoir à ses côtés
qu'est-ce qui dirait toiba net pour
rattraper le coup
au point où vous en êtes la future
heures je te mettrai bien cartouches
c'est remarquable